[Music]
[Music]
when we last left April it had been a
month since the initial outbreak and it
was starting to look like she may have
caught the virus December 27th her fears
had come true she was starting to
develop blisters and she had a fever
sweating profusely she was constantly
thirsty and was having trouble with
being able to keep focus and the guide
April notes down that she feels as
though she is made of pain the next
three days are filled with paranoid
entries that were caused by her high
fever she goes on to call the book of
supervillain monologue and accuses the
author of the book Warren merchant as
the mastermind behind the virus December
30th while still delirious from the
illness April was listening to Rick
velocity on the radio to try and
distract herself from the immense
discomfort suddenly she heard short
bursts of static over the radio she just
happened to be looking at the division
agent backpack at the same time and time
perfectly with the static the antenna on
the bag began to gleam without thinking
twice about her april cut off the
antenna and throw it out onto the window
onto one of the roofs below quickly
closing the window afterwards within
minutes
agents appeared at the scene she stared
down from behind a closed curtain and
watched as they look up and down at the
buildings around the next thing a
pronoun is that she was passed out on
the floor below the window the agents
were gone who were these agents they had
division gear and I was supposed to be
the good guys right but something just
didn't seem right about them but at this
point it have been three days and April
is coming to the realization that she
may have actually survived the dollar
flew as a fever clears she comes to the
conclusion that Warren created the spoke
instead to help people
December 31st April has beaten the
dollar flu but there are now rumors
circulating that the president and half
Congress has dead January first
everything is peaceful and quiet
April decides to take advantage of this
and heads over to the Chelsea Piers to
do some trading for goods she also
decides to start looking for Warren
merchant by examining the about author
page there are several pieces that just
seem out of place
it contains references to world war one
and a dutch soldier plus several other
dutch references this is the first clue
because of the growing violence in the
neighborhood
April thinks that it's now time to find
a new home January 4th April walks down
to Houston on the Lower East Side she's
looking for an area that isn't too quiet
but also isn't too busy she doesn't want
to move into a building controlled by
one of the hostile factions but also she
doesn't want to be the sole person
watching out for danger while scouting
the area she decides to return to the
doctor she figures at this point she may
be of assistance to them a sort of
informant on the street also she
survived the virus maybe she can help
with finding a cure after this she
visits the library to see if she can
find any more leads on the whereabouts
of merchant eventually she finds a book
with the same photo that was used in the
about author section she tears the page
from the book and ran from the library
as fast as she could librarians over
this time had turned into a sort of cult
protecting the books by any means
necessary and this is shown by the
number of bodies hanging from the upper
balconies throughout the building April
gets the feeling she's being followed
there is evidence that her belongings
have been tampered with she suspects
that whoever it was was looking for the
Survival Guide
January 5th April makes a new home in
the Lower East Side
on the fourth floor of the building she
strikes a deal with the family running a
restaurant on the ground floor there are
three other people living in the
building upon different floors there is
a lot of violence north of 14th Street
and the JTF is at risk of losing the
area to the Rockies and the lnb and if
this happens there will be a severe
reduction of incoming supplies at this
point April is done to respect the JTF
more and more and decides to try and
help them in any way that she could
because of a recovery against the virus
she volunteers to give blood samples
she also organizes a meeting the next
day with a JT of officer to help with
something called human intelligence
January 16 after examining the page she
took from the library she found that the
photo is actually a world war 1 French
resistance fighter called Jacobson yeah
whose real name is Philippe hola hola
created the pseudonym by combining the
name of the street he lived on with the
translation of a surname using this key
piece of information April was able to
figure out that merchants actual surname
was Koopman the English translation of
the Dutch word merchant and he could
possibly be found on Warren Street with
the addition of the information in the
book regarding a food truck April was
able to establish that she'll be able to
find the author mr. Koopman at 2 1-3
Warren Street
January seventh this address would take
April into a dangerous area of the city
but regardless she decided it was worth
it
however on arrival to the address she
doesn't find mr. Koopman instead she
finds a missing person poster and the
person on the poster was her how did he
know was he looking for it or has he
been watching her the whole time she
realizes that her earliest suspicions of
being watched were correct
there was a handwritten note from the
author on the back of the poster April
figured out that using the number on the
front there was a hidden message to be
translated April I've gone dark
come to 117 west 58 basement level
crouppen this address was located in the
dark zone but having come this far she
decides that she needs to keep pushing
forward as far as the Survival Guide is
concerned this is the last we hear of
her endgame was here at the start of
this journey as she bumps into Erin
keener on her way to the dark zone
[Music]
a friend looks familiar where are you
going
[Music]
for the walls
really be careful what you find in there
and Lord careful what you
but also through the hazard shield we
hear a conversation she had with the JTF
elfs it's to the right
[Music]
[Music]
convinced me that letting you go in
there is an assisted suicide I've been
in there before I can handle myself tell
you what I'll let you go but if you get
killed in there you don't come crying to
me okay
[Music]
traveling to the address in DZ 7 we can
find the location where Koopman was
hanging out inside there were stockpiles
of food water and medicine but most
interesting is a whiteboard that has
names and coordinates written on it most
of these are a bit of an easter egg
pointing towards the location of Ubisoft
related officers around the globe but
there is one that's a little different
April K these coordinates directors
straight back to the base of operations
however what happens after that is
unknown did April find Koopman or had he
already moved on did April head back to
the base of operations after meeting up
with Koopman or where the coordinates on
the whiteboard just notes about April's
location from much earlier on one thing
I do feel certain about is that the
April Kelliher story doesn't end here
whether there's another lead within the
book and game or maybe in the sequel
this isn't the last time we'll hear
about April Kelleher's fights to survive
and find answers about her husband's
death and his involvement in the Dola
flu
[Music]
as I stated in the first video of the
series a lot of this information is
found in the New York collapse book
written by Alex Irvine if you've enjoyed
the series I highly recommend getting a
hold of this book in fact if you've
enjoyed the in-game division story in
any way I recommend it the more I
referenced the book the more I realized
how much of over simplified the story
I mean I've given you the general gist
of how the story goes but in the book
there is so much more detail that you
can go into there may be a number of
clues and leads that have missed
literally every time I pick up the book
I find something that I haven't noticed
previously so what do you think do you
have any possible leads and what
happened to April Kelleher and where she
may be what about mr. Koopman I've seen
a number of interesting theories
including one from a member of our two
school community regarding an
inconsistent flashing light in the
corner of the base of operations up the
front by the bunk beds personally I
don't think we'll hear or find out any
more about the story until the next
books come out or the next iteration of
the game but at the same time I'll be
the first to admit that this is a large
open game and that there is a lot of
room for things to pop up otherwise if
you've made it this far thank you very
much for watching this has certainly
been one of the more interesting stories
I've covered and although this is the
end of the series I certainly haven't
finished looking into it and I'll
continue to follow any new theories and
leads that come up anyway thanks again
for watching and I'll catch you in the
next one Cheers